hey
and also
and now
i was
engaged to somebody in the industry and
sometimes what it does is people it
mentally can scar you
has anything changed since three years
ago for you relationship wise
[Music]
sex is sacred
three
two
one
go
i believe everybody has the opportunity
to choose what kind of sex they will
have how they want to have sex when they
want to have sex why they want to have
sex but then there's times i just want
to be a dirty pig and just go out and do
whatever i want and that's not sacred
i do think it can be and i also think it
cannot be the connection i think is very
important so it can be if if you're
connected to that person that way it
could be very sacred or else you can
just have sex without any emotions and
just a more physical awesome space
people don't really get it like when i'm
on set
um donnie's sentence when i'm at home
i'm normal me so when i have sex at home
there's like a connection there's love
there's all that other stuff there's
also not like a ring light and a camera
directly open up
let me see like the penetration you're
not being told that at home you're just
going with the flow buck and i were
actually talking about this earlier but
a lot of people
they're able to separate sex and
emotions and like feelings so it's not
always sacred in the way that people
think for me in my brain i registered
the same as like oh i went and worked
out at the gym with my friend
but the workout just happened to be sex
my family approves of what i do for a
living
three two one go
they're not all for they still want me
to go back to college they found out the
first day that my first scene came out
my mom she called me and she was upset
and then like a week after that she was
like you know i love you and like you're
still welcome to come home but they had
my back all of my family members they
had went to college ivy league schools
and i'm the only one that chose to
become a sex worker it was always an
awkward conversation until i completely
retired from doing in-person sex work
that tension is still there but they are
happy that i'm not performing or meeting
up with anyone in person so they're
comfortable with me just being an online
performer they're happy that i'm safe
and i'm healthy and i have a
income coming in before the industry i
used to
i i'm an addict i'm sober now but like i
used to get in a lot of trouble i was
living on the street it was a whole
thing and then the industry helped me
create a safe space for myself and also
do a lot of work on my mental health
they would prefer if i did something
else but they're not going to hate me
for doing it
it is hard for me to find a relationship
because of my job
three
two
one go
donnie let's start with you has anything
changed since three years ago for you
relationship wise
i was
engaged to somebody in the industry and
sometimes porn
can destroy you know relationships
and can destroy people you know because
i don't have her anymore
and honestly
i don't know if i ever will you know
because
sometimes what it does is people it
mentally can scar you
i'm still single
um
having sex with other people to most
people was just like not a normal thing
like i'm going to work and i'm going to
have sex with somebody as far as
relationships i feel like the only thing
that has really changed is i've accepted
that
some people just
it always starts off good and then after
a while they just feel a certain type of
way so
i'll read off some popular search terms
and then
you'll decide if it's problematic or not
problematic
to mouth three
two one go
porn is fantasy people porn is fantasy
is it problematic to use ass to mouth
well it depends on what you mean by
problematic yeah if someone does it
without having to clean
before they do it well they're going to
learn the hard way so
i think it's somewhat problematic
because people want to do that but like
you need to prepare correctly because on
movie sets they are cleaning themselves
out completely how do people clean
themselves with an enema
[Laughter]
milf
three
two one
go
milk to me is an empowerment term it's
you know we have a lot of ageism within
our industry as well as a lot of other
industries it's not problematic because
it's basically saying that that lady who
happens to be a mom is super hot and i'd
like to [ __ ] her i just feel bad
sometimes because you'll get the girl
and you're like oh you're the milk today
and she's like yeah but i'm 25.
she's like younger than you
put some makeup on her that made her
look older and put a dress on her team
three
two
one go
this one is tricky because i do fall in
the teen category a lot of men are pervy
and they love the whole fresh out of
high school
age play they love it and i'm going to
profit off it but it does get to the
point where it's a little bit too far
like when you want me to perform like
i'm under 18. i'm not going to act like
a 13 year old school girl like that's
just not gonna happen when i was 18 19 i
loved the teen category because i was
like oh people my age this is right up
my alley this is perfect it can be
somewhat problematic just because there
are people like that but it's also not
our responsibility to regulate if
somebody's going to be a creep but when
people see teen or any of that within
the porn space immediately people go to
sex trafficking it's a little
problematic because we're getting shoved
again into that space of sex trafficking
and teenagers and youngsters and you
know which none of us want to touch any
of that
covid has affected my job
three two
one go
i'm happy cope it happened i'm sorry
i have to say it kovan has put so much
money in my pocket that i have not seen
since i've started out and i think it
was because everyone was just locked up
in the house not knowing what was going
on in the world and the next thing that
they want was to be
in the comfort of their fantasy girl and
i was at fantasy girls that's why
everyone hopped on the wave of only fans
i even jumped back into webcam and and
my numbers skyrocketed it's weird but
people would rather see your laundry in
the background
than
nice furniture and paintings you know
yeah that reality is different
because it's the realness so i think
people really want realness polished
porn studio porn is going away when cove
would hit it affected me and like i
wasn't going to set anymore we had a
complete like shutdown in the industry
where nobody was filming some people
started making a lot of money but then
like other people who
were doing only mainstream they were
like what are we gonna do now you know
because they didn't have that so i feel
like i was lucky that i already had an
established online presence
sexual assault is prevalent in the
industry
three
two
one
go
it's a hot topic in our industry because
people want to be like no our industry
is good we want to protect each other
and there's such a big stigma against
what we do as a job that we're almost
afraid to speak up when something
happens how are we supposed to make
people accept porn if they know that
people are in the industry getting
assaulted sometimes i work in an
industry that's probably separate from
these people i work in more of the gay
adult industry so in my 20 plus years in
the adult industry i would say i have
not seen a lot of that happen of course
it happens and it does happen more in
the straight industry than it does in
the gay industry from my observation we
do have certain companies that do have
an entire checklist that you have to
sign and go through with the girl and
you guys talk about things but you have
people who still break rules you have
[ __ ] in this world that's what they
are i guess i'm the only one i strongly
agree
cause
i have encountered sexual assault
numerous times on sets but sometimes i
just hold it in when no situations
happen
until like a female performer she'll
tell me like oh like i'm shooting with
this person like i'll give her the heads
up but as far as like coming out i
literally have to wait for a big name to
speak up on a certain performer
to say something because i know if i was
to say something
no one would really believe me because
i'm like the underdog no one really has
my back like that i did a photo shoot it
was in a beautiful mansion with all
these beautiful instagram models
photographers everywhere
and i was getting ready to leave and
this photographer followed me to the
bathroom i didn't even know he was
behind me locked me in there and some
things happened he's so well connected i
knew i could not speak out about it or
say anything i had literally had to walk
out of this bathroom with a smile on my
face put a mask on and no one knew what
i had to endure for those 20 minutes
it's a power thing and they know they
can do that to you by the way i want to
say i am so sorry that happened to you
it's just not okay you scarred her like
you
there's things you can't take back
from set from content from anything
people should pay for porn
three
two
one
go
it's not a harmless thing to be stealing
porn because there's a huge industry
that's affected by it we're not legit in
a lot of people's eyes so on some level
they feel like they can take and steal
our stuff because they just don't have
compassion for us and they they don't
look at us as if we are actually running
a business we have to pay for everything
you see in our porn how do we pay for
that the only way we can get that money
is by you participating in us creating
that pornography we make a lot of people
happy when they get that nut off so
y'all should pay us
that's all i wanted to say
and like you guys asked us earlier this
is art
so you paid for every piece of art you
paid for the clothing you have on you
pay for glasses you pay for everything
so why not pay for porn the work that it
takes to do a video i think you guys
would be very surprised also i feel like
you guys should pay for porn if i mean
especially because you want to regulate
it we keep these things behind paywall
and behind like age restrictions to make
it so the adult movies are for adults if
you are a legit porn person like we all
are here we don't make it accessible to
children who's making it accessible to
children are the people who are putting
the free pornography on the internet
i would be comfortable with my child
following in my footsteps
three two one go
so i actually have a child and um not
that he's asked me hey dad can i get
into porn
that being said if he chose to do it i i
would say that i would try to steer him
a different direction because it's not
an easy industry to be in i do think
there's better choices for people to
make but i would not discourage him 100
percent i said agree
um not specifically for filming
mainstream porn
i was thinking more so the route of
contactless porn so like webcaming phone
sex operator even content creator
somewhere where my child our future
child doesn't have to have interaction
with the consumer as far as like in
person sex work
that will be a problem
because i know what could possibly
happen and i don't even want my worst
enemy to experience that so i wouldn't
want my child to experience that neither
it's a wrap
can we do a group hug good stuff yeah
great representation of the industry for
real we did an amazing job thanks guys
[Music]
you